you can never really have too much of
life and good health and right now
Africans are living longer healthier
lives the World Health Organization
recently announced that healthy life
expectancy on the continent has gone up
from 46 years at the start of the
Millennium to 56 years in 2019 that's
almost 10 extra years in which a person
lives in a good state of health
a key element is improving Health Care
for Women advancements in Health
Services like cancer screening could
lead to better and timely treatment the
World Health Organization estimated some
700 000 cancer deaths in Africa in 2020
in Cameroon one physician has come up
with a device that helps to ease
cervical cancer screening for women DW
news Africa's Blaise young reports from
yonde
has regular checkups
cervical cancer can be treated if
detected early and detection is
screening
for small clinics like this one in the
capital yahunde that used to be a
problem
there is no specialist doctor nor any
cancer screening machine so this smart
device has changed all that
this is the first time Sarah has tried
out the locally made kit
after the screening I feel totally fine
that's very different to the previous
tests that I've done the speculum was
very different the one they used before
was often very uncomfortable
traditional examinations use a metal
tool called a speculum to open up the
vagina
many women find that invasive and
distressing
health workers here are finding out
about the smart device for the first
time
it's made up of a mobile phone and a
smart specular
[Music]
area can screen her patients with a
smart kid in under 10 minutes this is a
major relief for people like her who
work in mother's health facilities
across the Central African nation
it is true that we do not have a
specialist here but thanks to this
equipment we can solicit the help of a
specialist from a distance who can help
with diagnosing a patient and provide
better care for the patients
the new tech was developed by Dr a 34
year old cameroonian medical doctor an
entrepreneur
the device sends data in real time and
diagnosis arrive within minutes
the information is later assessed
remotely by specialists
with these objective is that all women
no matter where they live no matter what
they are found no matter their social
economic levels can have access to uh
cervical cancer screening at a point of
Care
Dr Taco hopes to launch his smart cancer
screening Innovation across the
continent by next year
at the same time he continues to develop
other Tech solutions that can solve
Africa's Health needs
I'm now joined by that innovator you saw
in the report just now Dr Conrad tanku
from Hyundai in Cameroon welcome to DW
news Africa now can you tell us more
about this smart speculum and how it's
different from the traditional approach
uh thank you Tony for having me so uh
first just to give an idea of the
context right so this um Innovative must
become takes into consideration to
um very old Technologies one is called
the speculum right our technology that
was developable 100 years old
and the other is a corpuscope
um I mean the science behind it is that
it's like a microscope which permits you
to I mean the health provider to
visualize the cervix on a resilient LCD
screen right like a computer screen so
um first of all this corpuscope device
contrary and high and it's not really
available in developing settings and it
plays a really critical role in enabling
cervical cancer diagnosis right so what
we decided to do is
um to build around a new innovation by
incorporating these two technologies
into one into one portable
um easy to use device which can uh
easily adapt to the developing World set
and the special in rural areas and be
able to be easily used by low skill or
providers we're talking about nurses who
are mainly finding for our areas so
right basically incorporate the speculum
and Corpus call and I believe you've got
um two samples to show us how how they
compare
good so uh just to give an idea of what
a normal speaker looks like so this is
what it is I think women should
um know this device right so this device
permits I helped provider to be able to
visualize the service but
um it has limitations in on two cases
but for the patients it's sometimes
uncomfortable or painful as you respect
on examinations
and for the healthcare provider
sometimes um the other way they cannot
properly visualize the service after in
certain bits so right we decided to
renovate and come up with another smart
speaker device which is
um like this right uh personally can
compare is a smaller size and from the
choice of paradox of high it grows to be
more comfortable for the women and
provides a better visibility of the
cervix for the hardcore provider and to
bring you the idea of being
um incorporating the corpuscope um our
technology is that now with this device
we're able to visualize the solids on
the smartphone uh instead of the high
costly LCD screens which are being used
by corpuscope so we have this device
which is portable yeah okay that's
interesting so so you've sort of
simplified the whole process is this a
world first
yeah of course it's it's the first time
integrating both devices into one and
coming out with the possible couples cup
which work as a speculum and as a
corpuscopy the same device
well then congratulations on on this
Innovation um
you also have breast cancer screening
that you carry out as well
yeah I mean the objective of the product
project jic made is actually to Target
the two most common cancers in
sub-Saharan Africa and the philosophy
about this is that both car cancers
um
um account for more than 50 percent of
all cancers in sub-Saharan African women
so we can Target both of them then
there's a huge impact with the creating
and and you're able to sort of use
technology to bring these Services
closer to people wherever they may be
but of course there are issues to do
with electricity power outages are those
a problem where you are
of course I mean we're taking the
consideration the context while
developing this technology so of course
it's very difficult context talking
about
um electricity Supply as well as
internet connectivity as well but of
course pure co-creation design model we
try to incorporate all of this to have
the most adapted solution to the context
and I think this is what stands up
um with web recruiters so far to be able
to adapt to the local context all right
Dr Conrad tanku from Yaounde in Cameroon
many thanks for speaking to us
thank you
to Uganda where one doctor is winning
the hearts of his patients at his
private Clinic Timothy o'kello Lost His
sight to an infection but he has not
lost his medical expertise in fact he's
thriving at his job and helping to fight
stigma against the visually impaired
DW's Julius mugambua reports from
Kampala
this might look like a routine medical
examination but it is not Dr Timothy
okello is blind so to diagnose his young
patient he uses all his other senses
the mother has complete trust in his
special way of treating her child
who works compassionately and he
cares for you and you feel like you even
okay before you can work on you
there's a way he has a touching and a
Healing Hand
that's why we can't even look for him
from where we are from up to where he is
now in 2011 okello had been practicing
as a doctor for five years but then he
was diagnosed with a rare eye infection
called oveitis they did some surgery
there and gave me some treatment
came back improved
six months down the road still it failed
so
I just had to accept what had come my
way and I settled for blindness okello
says that adapting to blindness has been
a challenge both at a personal and
professional level but his mental
resilience has helped him to cope
I strongly believe that every challenge
has a solution
so I sat down and I had it come up with
the way that how best can I practice my
medicine
with the limitation which I've gotten
okello works with a full-time ad who
does all the visual investigations such
as seeing symptoms and taking notes
The Physician says that more than 10
years of blindness have made him a
better listener
my hearing it's so shopping ever since I
lost my sight and it helps me a lot even
sometimes I just listen to the breaths
of the baby I listen and I will tell
that no the way this baby is breathing
there is a problem
if I'm far away from my stethoscope I
request for it and I pick it more
clearly
according to the World Health
organization's regional office about 15
percent of the global population of
blind people are estimated to be in
Africa
says that they face many forms of
discrimination
through public talks the advocates for
their rights
sometimes if somebody does not know your
background it is hard to believe that
you can do something it is hard for an
employer to believe that you can deliver
ocalo inspires the blind Community this
football team has asked him to Lobby
support for the blind using his
influence the way I've seen all these
guys were I've come here most of them
don't have Mobility appliances that our
devices that they use to move for
example white canes so it's going to
help us to link up with to link to a
wolf getting those Mobility appliances
and other support and equipment that we
can use in our game and also in the day
today running over activities
ocello may have lost his sight but not
the capacity to impact the people he
touches with a Healing Hand